well here's how you make an IQ test it's
really easy and everyone should know
this because you need to know how these
things work so imagine that you took a
universal library of questions any sort
of question that required abstraction to
solve could be a general knowledge
question it could be a vocabulary
question could be a mathematical
question it doesn't matter it could be a
question about anything as long as it
requires abstraction to solve so you
have a universal library of those
questions then imagine you took a
hundred questions at random from that
Universal library and you gave them to
500 people and then you just totalled
their scores right right wrong total
total scores then you rank ordered the
scores from highest performer to lowest
performer that's IQ that's all there is
to it
that's it and then what you'd find is if
you took another hundred questions from
the same library randomly selected and
gave them to the same 500 people and
you'd have to rank orders right from
from the top to the bottom the
correlation between the two rank orders
would be about point nine unbelievably
high it's unbelievably stable and now if
you correct that for age you get IQ
that's all there is to it